in the market for a new car and won a
luxury experience for
a non-luxury price thinly acura has you
covered
[Music]
my name is travis we're here at finley
acura in the valley auto mall
and we are the best kept secret here in
the valley offering a
luxury experience at a non-luxury price
we're
very proud of our customer satisfaction
you could
check that out online very highly rated
the google
yelp all the main platforms all of our
social media
[Music]
when you do visit our location you'll be
greeted by a
friendly staff member here one of our
finley team members
and our goal isn't to pressure you into
a purchase you know we want you to
help consult with you and help you
through this process
we understand that you may just be
shopping around and that's what we're
here for
we do offer exceptional service very
highly rated online
we have a loaner vehicles that are
available for our customers
if they're going to have their vehicle
here for an extended period of time we
have all of our amenities in service
as far as big screen tvs soda machine
water
and coffee cappuccino available for them
as well now is a great time to purchase
a vehicle
um we have high uh trade-in values we're
looking for
vehicles to purchase all the time so
whether you purchase a vehicle or not
you know that's something that we'd love
to be able to give you an offer on your
vehicle as well
[Music]
so whether you're in the market for a
pre-owned vehicle something to
fit into a cash budget whether you're
looking for a third road suv something
for the family
or something for cruising the strip a
little more fun we have everything
that you could need here at findlay
acura so if you are looking for
luxury experience at a non-luxury price
we want you to think
acura and think finley acura so if
you're thinking acura i think auto ball
give finley acura a call at 702-982-4100
or you can visit their website
finleyacura.com